[Music]  gee whatever I do I do it to protect you  see understand I understand  [Applause]  [Music]  we have intercepted a coded Imperial  transmission it indicates that a major  weapons test is imminent we need to know  how to destroy it  so why me the message was sent by your  father they call it the desktop it's  capable of destroying an entire planet  it could be the end of us all  if my father built it we need to find  him I want to help  we'll need the team I've been recruiting  for the rebellion spies saboteurs  assassins Hey  you almost shot me  no world cargo shuttle what's your  callsign it's me  rogue one plunge it but I walk but we  are dealing with hair  is immeasurable I'll pass don't have to  come one echo where he goes  please take the next chance  be with me all the way  light it up  [Music]  you're letting her keep it  would you like to know the probability  of her using it against you  it's high